hello everyone and welcome to a very
nice game that perfectly illustrates how
even being a billionaire will not make
you immune to missing mates in one I'm
talking about an event that takes place
after the st. Louis rabid elites event
all of the players who participated in
this event are divided into two teams we
have a team Wrexham field sing field and
team Randy C sing field now here is a
nice photo by Leonard oats that will
describe the playing venue and you know
give you a feel of the atmosphere a
currently there are maxima sherrilyn
Grove and Anand at the board but every
player makes five moves and then another
player takes his place so it's very
interesting because the two amateurs Rex
and Randy are then replaced by top world
elite chess players and then they after
you know everyone made it their turns it
all returns to Rex and Randy so inc team
Rex
we have Fabiano Caruana Wesley saw
Sergei Kirk in Maxim for Sheryl grove
shafter mom in Europe and Peter Svidler
and in team Randy
we have magnus carlsen Hikaru Nakamura
11 Oregon Vishwanathan Anand Alexander
Griff shook and linear Dominguez so
first at the board there are Randy
sinful and Rex Sinquefield
Randy opens the game with the white
pieces and he opens it with c4 we have
c5 so the symmetrical variation of the
English II for g6 Knight to f3 and the
Knight to c6 d for C capture Sundy for
knife capture son before and now we
enter the accelerated dragon variation
of the Sicilian Bishop g7 is on the
board here Randy and Rex leave the table
and there they are replaced by magnus
carlsen and Charlie and Momiji arrow
across and immediately after coming to
the table plays the Bishop to e3 as he
enjoys playing this Marazzi set up
against the accelerated dragon knight to
f6 Knight to c3
we have castles Bishop to e2 d6 this is
all standard theory of the accelerated
dragon castles Bishop to d7 and calls
and retreats with the night Knights the
c2 here they leave the table and they
are replaced by Hikaru Nakamura
Sergei kurakin there you have it team
Rex everyone is eagerly awaiting what
will happen and the board cause a
hurricane contemplating his next move
how to go about this night to see to
move rook to see a it's a c8 displayed
we have f3 solidifying that eforp on a6
by kurakin wrote to c1 by Nakamura and
then now Knight to e5 knife to a3 by
Nakamura and now comes Queen to a5 Queen
to b3 going for the b7 pawn and now b5
Kirkland goes for a very nice pawn
sacrifice but he will get a lot of
activity for it
Knight to d5 now we have Knight captures
on d5 and here again both of them leave
the board and onion and Wesley so
replaced them here there you have it
Aragon and his team figuring out what
what to do here everyone is checking out
the position except Carlsen it's very
difficult to figure out what Carlson is
looking at but ok after Knight captures
we have see captors on d5 by our en rock
to be 8 by Wesley and now comes h3
Knight to c4 Knight captures pawn
captures and now Queen has to return to
d1 and Wesley simply grabs the pawn rook
captures on b2 Bishop captures on c4 and
now comes Bishop to b5 again here both
are onion and Wesley leave the table and
they are replaced with Viswanathan Anand
and Fabiano Caruana
and here we have a very nice move rook
to f2 by anand rook captures by an f2 by
Fabiano Bishop captures an f2 and Bishop
captures on c4 rook captures on c4 and
now Queen captures on a 2 rope to a for
attacking the Queen and the pawn on e6
Queen B - and now rook captures on a6
and here we have h5 the final move made
by Fabiano Caruana both of them leave
the board and they are now replaced with
Alexander Alicia and Peter Svidler
there you have it there is Alexander
Grichuk and there is also Peter Svidler
you can see that the group is very eager
to find a move everyone else is
distracted by something but you know
grief shock really wants to find it the
best move and fiddler is as always happy
just to play chess so we have looked the
b6 now a very nice move attacking the
Queen Queen 283 and now Queen to b1 and
preparing a rook to b8 we have Bishop to
f6 so when the Queen does come to the
back rank the bishop will also be
guarding these some pawn rook b8 rook
capture some be a the Queen captures an
b8 and here we have a king to g7 Queen
to be won and here comes Queen to c3
here again both degrees chickens fiddler
leave the board and they are replaced
with a linear Dominguez and the Machine
washer graph Queen to d1 is played by
Dominguez Bishop to e5 by Maxine g4 now
and here
Maxine pushes f5 and this is really
asking for trouble there were there was
no reason to open up the position like
this but it's it's all good
King G to F captors on g4 f captain g4
and now Queen to be to pinning that
bishop on f2 preparing if the white
white we never moves Bishop to d4 will
be an idea here Dominguez plays G
captures on h5 and here you have to
capture G captures on h5 and after Queen
captures this Bishop to b4 pin will be
sufficient for black to draw this game
but here after G captors on h5 Maxime
for sure holograph pushed in g5 and this
allows the whites to go for something
more than a draw here after g5 once
again we have team Randy and team Rex
Randy sinful and Rex Sinquefield come to
the board and here white can really
really push for something but he has to
play the absolute best moves and here
Randy Sinquefield does go for it he goes
Queen to g4 of course the threat is
Queen captures on g5 so brush up to f6
defending it and now we have H for
another best move that threatens to open
up the position
King to h6 adding further protection to
the g5 pawn but this simply doesn't work
here H captures on g5 was played this is
not the best move this allows the black
the game if he had played Queen to f5
here with the threat of Queen G's g6
checkmate then it's all over
after King captures Queen to h7 is
coming and after King comes to g4 h
captures and g5 King captures and now
King to f3 and as you can see there are
no squares for the King to go to there
there's no way for for black prevented
Bishop to e3 check whatever you do even
if you check him still better to e3
check is coming and the King has no
moves all of the squares around the King
are covered you would have to capture
here and white wins but as this is you
know a friendly event you know H
captures on g5 with Czech Bishop
captures on e5 and now Queen to e6 with
Czech and here once again we have a
position where black can easily draw the
game after king captures here Queen to
f7 Czech can come back King to h6 will
allow black to simply avoid all the
checks and the White will not have any
chances of improving his position but
after this Queen to e6 check we have
Bishop to f6 and now once again the game
is lost for black but it's lost if you
play Queen to f7 after Queen to f7 there
is no defense against Queen to g6
checkmate but here once again Randy goes
for Queen to g4 and here yet again
refracts plays Bishop to g5 he can
defend checkmate and all is well but the
problem is here in this position Rex
Sinquefield the billionaire played Queen
to e5 and left the board both Randy and
him left the board and we even have a
photo of this moment also a nice photo
by laner totes there we have it no one
can believe it Rex just made the move
cost and already replaced Randy at the
board Nakamura really can't believe it
everyone is really enjoying themselves
having a lot of fun and here of course
there is now I'm eighteen one Queen g6
will be checkmate and it was actually in
Mahmud Yaffe's turned to sit at the
board but he really didn't want to do it
you really don't want to sit next to
cousin and experience this queen g6 move
over the board so he tried pushing
Kuryakin to take his place and so
correct in what
to be checkmated on g6 ah but then he of
course arrived at the board he shook
Coulson's hand and crossed and simply
played queen g6 checkmate and it was all
over so a very nice a very nice game in
a very nice event that really you know
brought a lot of happiness to everyone I
will put a link to the original video
footage in the description below so you
can check it out this game starts
somewhere at around 30 minute mark so
feel free to check it out it's very
enjoyable everyone you know everyone is
really putting their you know giving
their best and everyone is really really
funny Ariane is really really a big
jokester Aki often says that they have
like they they control more space they
have better pieces placement and they
have better players so of course they
will win this game even though the
position was completely drawn or
sometimes he will say I'm just gonna
grab the pawn and as I'm leaving the
table I will let the other guy think
about it so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Danny McCullough Daniel grout and
Michael cutter for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as you really can check
two of my previous videos here thank all
for watching and I'll see you soon with
some of your suggestions and until I
prepare the official Larson series still
gonna like I said go through some of
your suggestions so thank you all and
I'll see you soon